Dubai is a very flamboyant country with
Lamborghini police the Burj Kalifa and
the palm islands but what's even more
surprising is that Dubai has been able
to accomplish this with no sales or
income tax imposed on any of its
residents
considering that Dubai is not an
oil-rich city like many of its
neighbours with less than 5% of its GDP
being derived from oil how is Dubai not
only able to operate but thrive well
starting off Dubai operates more like a
private business rather than a country
in fact a lot of their income is from
businesses that they own like Emirates
and the Burj Al Arab but those are just
the most well-known ones Dubai owns a
plethora of other companies under
various holding companies like the Dubai
Holding Company which owns the Zhu
Mariah group to buy properties tecum
group air Media Group Dubai
International Capital and more and if
you dive into each of these companies
you'll find even more subsidiary
companies for instance the tecum group
is comprised of the Dubai internet City
health care city media City Studio City
knowledgeable äj-- industrial city and
many more as you can see Dubai is
heavily invested in many businesses
inside the country which generate
billions of dollars of profit per year
Emirates alone pulled in 62 million
dollars in the first half of 2018 and
this was after an 82 percent decrease in
profit due to high fuel prices moving on
Dubai also has other sorts of business
revenue that are unique to its location
Dubai is located near the tip of the
Arabian Peninsula right next to the
Persian Gulf this optimal location has
allowed them to build up a very busy
port called a port of Jebel Ali which is
a ninth busiest port in the world with
an annual container volume of 13 point 6
million on top of this
they're very modern sleek city has been
very appealing to many film and TV show
directors way back in 2011 Dubai was
able to earn 40 million dollars from
just film and TV production clearly
Dubai makes a lot of money from their
business ventures but that's only a
third of the puzzle next up is tourism
obviously there's a lot of money to be
made for Dubai off of two
as many of the most popular tourist
destinations are government-owned
but this is just the beginning tourists
are charged up to 10% tax on their hotel
rooms and may also face municipality
fees service charges city tax and a
tourism fee there is even a departure
tax which is including the costs of
buying a flight ticket landing or
departing from Dubai all of these
tourist taxes coupled with the high
tourism volume in Dubai
generate billions of dollars in revenue
in 2018 thirty point eight two billion
dollars was spent by just overnight
international visitors in Dubai
considering that Dubai brings in the
most tourist dollars worldwide it's not
hard to see why such an integral part of
their economy though residents of a
Dubai don't have to pay sales or income
taxes there are still fees to pay like
the housing fee the housing fee applies
if you are renting in which case you are
obligated to pay five to ten percent of
her internal rent to the government this
covers common community services like
garbage collection street cleaning
landscaping and irrigation another
source of revenue is any sort of
government issued license like driver's
licenses driver's licenses are very
expensive in Dubai ranging between 4500
to 7500 their homes or 1200 to $2,000 if
you're able to pass by your first try
each additional attempt will cost you
1200 to 1500 dear homes or 300 to 400
dollars if you do get a driver's license
well you should be a good law-abiding
driver because you definitely do not
want to face a speeding ticket and don't
think you are safe if you don't see any
police nearby see the Lamborghini please
are more of a show and most piant Achatz
are issued by device highly advanced
network of speeding cameras speeding
tickets range from 100 to $3,000 based
on how much you break the speed limit by
and as you aren't stopped each time your
speed it's very easy to rack up
thousands of dollars in fines for
instance this one british tourist was
able to rack up over 47,000 dollars in
fines in just four hours speeding up to
one hundred and fifty
miles per hour with a bunch of multi
millionaires and billionaires living in
Dubai with supercars it's easy to see
how speeding tickets are great source of
revenue for the Dubai government after
issuing driver's licenses
speaking of licenses to get a business
license will cost you over $8,000 per
year but again the good thing is that
you don't have to pay them any taxes so
this is actually a much better option
for most businesses moving on partying
is frowned upon in Dubai
especially when it includes alcohol
being drunk in public can get your rest
and lead to hefty fines but even before
that alcohol itself carries hefty taxes
of 50% import tax and 30 percent alcohol
tax furthermore carbonated beverages are
taxed at 50% and tobacco and energy
drinks are taxed at 100% but don't get
me wrong here if we just stick to rules
and don't party you can take home tens
of thousands of dollars more compared to
most countries however given the
demographics in Dubai many people end up
paying many of these fees in the end
Dubai is able to thrive without taxes on
its residents due to the plethora of
government owned businesses high income
from tourism along with hefty fines and
fees four people would like to live a
little on the edge this diversification
of income initially rose out of
necessity as Dubai didn't have much oil
revenue but today it has a clearly paid
off longest residents to live mostly
tax-free and Dubai is very proud of this
their vice-president Sheikh Mohammed bin
Rashid Al Maktoum has declared that his
country would never adopt income tax as
a way to tackle deficit so this
situation seems applicable to Dubai for
the foreseeable future but that's what I
think what do you guys think about Dubai
make sure to comment that down below
also if you guys thought this video
clearly explained how Dubai thrive
without implementing taxes they
mentioned drop a like and consider
subscribing if like to see more
questions just like this one logically
answered but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next one